okay so Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is
now out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the full movie
It's Easter eggs ending and also those
post credit scenes
are you ready
for One Last Ride
featuring the final outing for this
version of the Guardians this also
closes the book on James Gunn's time at
Marvel Now moving over to DC this is the
director's last film before he starts
running the show over at the Studio's
main competitor hey everybody I'm James
Gunn I'm the co-ceo of DC Studios I'm
gonna be getting into it all but heavy
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then check out
now I also want to give a huge thank you
to our sponsors comicbookdirect.com
who've helped make this video got tons
of graphic novels and if you're a
physical collector like I am then you
definitely need to check this place out
as it feels like it was built for fans
like us they work with all the major
Publishers like Marvel in DC and the
best thing about this site is that if
you're in the middle of a run you can
subscribe to it to get every issue sent
out directly as they release really cool
site and if you use the link below
you're gonna get 20 off your first order
they've also got manga and figures so if
you want to get those brand new
Guardians Funko Pops then definitely
head over to the link in the description
[Music]
now this movie's been in development for
a number of years due to not only the
pandemic but also because James Gunn got
fired by Disney the look for a directed
to fill his shoes but after everyone
turned them down where did their failure
bring them back to me hit him now
because of this the order of things has
been switched slightly as Thor was
originally supposed to feature in this
film instead of the Guardians popping up
at the start of love and thunder still
though the plot threads left at the end
of Avengers end game are still very
apparent with Peter pining after his
long-lost love Gamora she becomes a
pivotal character too with her now
leading the ravages and this is all
about bringing the family together
before we finally say goodbye and the
movie itself begins with a flashback of
Rocket AKA subject 89p13 this
designation summing that he's known as
in the comics and it's also the name
that we saw pop up in the prison scene
in the first Guardians movie Underneath
this we could see that his known
associate to a Lila who is a big
character in the comics that makes a
debut here don't really know why she's
classed as an associate as she
unfortunately dies before seeing freedom
and she gets really devastating
character Journey that pushes rocker to
become the way he is we'll all play away
together
one last time
to the forever
in the sky
the subject number is also tattooed on
him which is highly reminiscent of the
Holocaust and how the Jews were treated
now amongst the cage full of other
raccoons he's picked by the high
evolutionary and the early experiments
we end up seeing highly resemble how his
Origins played out in the source
material we discover that the high
evolutionaries been attempting to create
a Utopia and that he's built a machine
which speeds up the evolution process by
millions of years within seconds this
turns them into Angry Monsters though
and it's only through Rocket's
intervention that he perfects the
process this allows him to create a
so-called perfect species which
frustrates him because he owes it all to
something that he sees as an Abomination
along with rocket we of course get Lila
blow and also thiefs got a lot of sidden
Toy Story vibes from it as they all get
things like either mechanical arms metal
teeth feet for wheels and so on and so
forth although it seems like the high
evolutionary views rocket is a companion
he actually just wants to incinerate him
and his friends now that he's figured
out the process rocket manages to escape
but sadly his allies are killed leading
to him being out on his own in the
Galaxy he did however claw out the high
evolutionary space on his way out and
we'll talk about this reveal with this
later on in the video now in the holiday
special we saw that Peter returned to
the bottle and that's very much the case
here with a lot of scenes echoing the
way he was in the special presentation
not even the gift of Kevin Bacon could
stop the Seven Degrees of Separation
he's feeling and without her he's left
like a hollow man any other night now we
begin these scenes with rocket listening
to his zoon and muttering along to the
songs which comes full circle at the end
when he and everyone start dancing to
the Dog Days Are Over by Florence and
the Machine anyway out of nowhere Adam
Warlock arrives on nowhere in order to
grab rocket he's a big addition to the
MCU and we got our first tease to him
all the way back in the last Guardians
movie they actually did things in a
weird order as warlock was someone who
primarily wanted her with Thanos in the
infinity storylines that spanned several
years warlock in the comics possesses
the Soul Stone on his forehead which was
gifted to him by by the high
evolutionary in the source material he
was also originally made with draxen
even a love interest of Gamora which is
a Direction they could go with this
multiversal version anyway after first
appearing in fantastic 467 the character
was originally created on Earth by the
group known as The Enclave simply
referred to as him he was renamed Adam
Warlock by the high evolutionary which
is sort of adapted into this film they
could stuff out with the enclave and
instead just have the high evolutionary
crate in The Sovereign which then went
on to go and create Adam known as the
Warlock he was pulled out the podali
which is why he's slightly
underdevelopmentally now he ends up
learning empathy through the little
animal blurb whose voice is provided by
D Bradley Baker this is kind of also
gun's audition for Superman with him
possessing all the powers and more that
the Man of Steel does what he doesn't
have though is his developed mind though
and instead Adam's more like a fish out
of water learning his way in the world
you could say he was born yesterday who
the greatest
now along with him is the high
evolutionary who's a big character that
also comes from the comics in the movie
he says that he journeyed to Earth and
this is likely where he picked up rocket
however it doesn't seem like he's
actually from there like how he is in
the source material however he has an
obsession with our music and sees all
the elements of Sam being brought
together to create something beautiful
as a motif that he can adapt into his
Creations now the comic said I'm being
born in Manchester under the name
Herbert Wyndham at the start of the 20th
century early on in his childhood he
moved out to the Welsh Countryside with
his parents and this happened during the
1920s yeah he learned the work of
Nathaniel Essex aka the X-Men villain
known as Mr Sinister working away in his
parents basement he carried out
experiments on rat fascinated with
attempting to genetically engineer
animals to be what is sick and twisted
heart desired studying signs for the
majority of his life he was eventually
given a serum to unlock genetic codes
but the controversy around his
experiments got him expel from Oxford at
this point he moved to wundergore
Mountain which they ended up bringing a
cross into Multiverse of Madness
speaking of Wonder we learn in the
comics that she and her brother had been
born in the mountain where cathon's
power touched them the high evolutionary
even got them the Midwife in Bova which
we actually got on to at the start of
One Division episode two it might
possibly tie this all in because it's a
human cow but they might not I just
thought I'd go over it and waste your
time anyway like the comics the high
evolutionary also created counter Earth
of which we see in this film there's
lots of animal cruelty in this movie
with a high evolutionary easily being
the most sadistic villain that we've
ever had in the MCU he's Peter's worst
nightmare and I don't mean quill no
these days we messed up what he does
there's lots of scenes with them that I
think are really difficult to watch and
he's gonna be someone who leaves a big
impression on everyone leaving the film
now warlock decapitates crude and he
leaves him like a spider head which I
think is a nod to the thing he almost
kills Drax and blast rocket with a beam
and this leaves the character being at
that store in the end nebula is the one
who ends up bringing Adam down and she's
slowly becoming one of my favorite
characters in the MCU I think Karen
Gillen really came into her own with a
character during endgame and she's
actually gone through an arc in these
movies and turning from a villain to a
hero and we learned that built into
rocket is a kill switch that will
Flatline the character if they use a med
pack to try and heal his wounds having
just 48 hours until he dies they head
out looking for a way to save him which
takes him to what I think is a company
called orgo Corp scribbled it down in
the cinema looks like nothing in the
light of day and I can't quite remember
what they were called but I think it was
that anyway on there where they
encounter the new ravages leader in
Gamora and after teaming up with her
they discover that the key file on
Rocket's part in one of the high
evolutionaries recorders these are
people that are basically mantets from
June and they serve the high
evolutionary in all of his experiments
the team break into orgo Corp HQ to get
the data and it's basically reverse
prison scene from that first movie the
entire location is pretty much James
Gunn's friend and family and we get
cameos from Nathan Fillion Jennifer
Holland when I think is Daniela malquia
and probably the guy who plays John
economos couldn't fully tell if it was
him under the makeup but judging by the
rest of the place I'm guessing that it's
him now they learned that the data
needed is in the recorder and from here
they head out to counter Earth now on
the other side of this we discover why
the evolutionary once rocket so badly
and that Adam walk and Aisha have been
high to track him down as some of the
team head out to deal with the
evolutionary we watch as Adam goes to
get Rocket which leads to him even going
toe-to-toe with the evolutionaries war
Pig the other part of the team end up
getting to the villain's base which is
where we discover that he wants to
destroy the planet and start again he
seeks Perfection Above All Else and Kana
Earth has ended up becoming as messed up
as their own planet is Peter manages to
get his hands on the recorder but the
planet's still destroyed along with
Adam's mother Aisha now back on the ship
they try and heal rocket but
unfortunately he flat lines which sends
him into the Afterlife her death is
something that they've studied a show
more and more on the MCU with us
discovering the afterlife somewhat
personalized construct depending on what
you want it to be I believe that that
when you die you get stuck in a room
with Dua Lipa and you get to I have my
own beliefs and we've seen with
characters like Moon Knight and Jane and
love and thunder that other afterlifes
exist in Rockets he sees cages along
with Lila thieves and flaws in what
becomes a really heartbreaking scene now
the other Guardians I.E Drax nebula
romantis went out to rescue Peter and
crude and they get stuck on the ship as
it travels into space they discover the
evolutionaries being creating children
with platinum hair one of which we learn
is phylaval this is actually a big
character in the Marvel Universe and
she'll likely time with Captain Marvel
at some point down the line she ended up
taking up the mantle in her own reality
though it has to be said there are other
versions of it however I think they
might stick with that one and it will
give that role as a mantle that can be
passed on anyway the Guardians end up
following the evolutionary out into
space and we get a fight in which the
villages as hell spawn whilst craglin
uses a massive Cannon built into
nowhere's eye it's such a cool action
scene that uses an incredible landmark
in the MCU that I wasn't expecting to be
brought across like this quilling Gamora
go to attack but Adam boards the ship
which causes it to crash land on the
evolutionary's vessel Peter uses the
self-destruct to try and kill Adam but
he ends up Surviving and in the end
group saves him because everyone
deserves a second chance and with this
we also get the appearance of the
creatures from the start of the second
guardian's film and these are tamed by
mantis come the end of the movie she
goes off into the Galaxy with them and
this is an order to try and find herself
she's someone who is just used as a
servant by ego and even upon joining the
Guardians she too ended up just
following their orders so the movie ends
for her with her saying her goodbyes to
the group and I have to admit had a
little tear on my eye just like Drax did
and we also get an incredible one take
scene with the Guardians all uniting
together and I think this is probably
the standout and guns portfolio when it
comes to directing I love one is and
just seeing how well choreographed and
put together this is completely blew me
away anyway after freeing all of the
evolutionaries animals and experiments
they get them on board nowhere whilst
rocket finally learns water [__] is at
this point the high evolutionary arrives
and beats the crap out of him calling
him a9p13 but Rocket says he's no longer
that he's Rocket Raccoon which is a
great little character moment and after
blasting away at the villain the
Guardians arrived to smash him like it's
a like button this point we also learn
what really happened to his face all
those years ago when rocket first
scratched at it geised in a Robocop and
pulled his skin over his skull to stop
him looking like her Two-Face what if
his face was symmetrical now the
Guardians don't end up killing him and
though his ships destroyed it there is
potential we could get an X-Men tie-in
due to his ties to Nathaniel Essex Essex
has appeared as a name throughout the
X-Men movie with Essex Corp featuring in
Logan Deadpool 2 and the New Mutants
whether Mr Sinister never showed up in
the films and with them bringing across
certain elements of those movies into
the MCU they could end up carrying them
across them into this universe uh Peter
rushes to grab as soon as the
evolutionary ship explodes and though it
seems like he's gonna die in the car
vacuum of space he saved by Adam Warlock
anyway the Guardians returned to the bar
in nowhere for one final goodbye and Gru
actually says I love you guys though the
dog days are over though they must go
their separate ways and it's a very
Bittersweet way to close out this movie
I was thinking that Peter and Gamora
might end up hooking back up but they
have a sort of mature goodbye in which
she says she imagined that he and her
other version had fun together there was
like two two tiny well three tiny bits
in the movie where it got me and the
first was the big hug scene after Peter
lived the second bit was with mantis
going off and then this moment of Gamora
Imagining the life they had whilst Peter
actually remembered it now the
relationship being oh it shows that
there are actually consequences and
though Gamora was brought back she isn't
the same person James Gunners talked
openly about how he felt like death in
his films should be final but there has
been the Multiverse that's kind of been
in doing this does I think a small way
to show that things matter was to not
have them end up together Peter decides
to head back to Earth and this brings
things full circle from that first movie
in the final scene with him we watch as
he reunites with his grandfather who was
the first person that brought him in to
see his mother in that first film Peter
ended up disappearing Without a Trace
after he was picked up by yondu and he's
avoided Earth as it's very much become a
place of trauma for him in a dying
breath his mother asked for him to take
her hand but he ran away from this and
was then taken off world to me he's
definitely tried to bury this and
probably felt guilt over running out on
her before she passed away I think a lot
of people can relate to avoiding the
scene of a trauma like this and though
Peter has been back to Earth he's not
went back to his family him returning
home brings sings full circle with him
reuniting with a family that he lost the
Guardians movie were very much about him
creating his own family with this bunch
of Misfits but now he's returned back to
his original one the first movie was
about the group being formed and the
second was about his dad who he ended up
realizing wasn't all he was cracked up
to be throughout the trilogy he's been
trying to create a version of his family
when his real one was back on Earth by
this entire time he goes to his
grandfather's house and asks his wife if
Mr quill is there which is when he
finally goes in the backyard and the
pair Embrace now in the second post
credit scene we see the opposite side of
this with him having breakfast alongside
his granddad we see him reading a
newspaper that says Kevin Bacon abducted
by aliens which of course ties back to
that holiday special anyway an
interesting thing happens with the text
here at the end of the movie this always
talks about characters returning and for
this we get the title saying the
legendary Star-Lord will return now I
talked about this in our post credit
scene video but in case you missed that
then there's one of two things that I
can see happening the legendary
Star-Lord is the name of his solo comic
book series and who knows we might even
get a film titled that centered around
the character so far we haven't had any
follow-ups to this film announced in
this slide but with a line like that we
may get something like this Chris Pratt
hasn't said whether he'd like to come
back or not but with the text being like
this I think there's a possibility
however I think that the most likely
outcome is that we will see the
character come back but either Kang
Dynasty or of course Secret Wars if you
read the comics then you'll know that
the Earth gets transformed into battle
World which is a match of all realities
it heavily pulls in the 616 Universe
which Peter is of course a member of of
unless it makes sense that he could be
brought across by this if Earth is
reformed and Peter is on it then it's
easy just to pick him up and integrate
him into the story however they might
all see Secret Wars as a way to bring
across another aspect that I'm guessing
this Multiverse Saga is going to focus
on unlike the other Marvel movies the
text at the end appears in a white
background and this is instead of the
usual black one with the white text this
might show that we'll get a similar
starlord of what's come before but that
there could be something slightly
different about him potentially the
Multiverse being open means that we
could get another Star-Lord and they
might do a variant for their film or
recast the actor going forward have you
even seen this in the likes of Zoe
Saldana who's been very open that Gamora
should be recasting the MCU and recently
she's been giving interviews saying just
please let me go please now from what
I've been told about the plans of Secret
Wars we're sort of heading for a soft
reboot and it'll likely bring in
multiple aspects of the expanded Marvel
Universe and united into one timeline
it's also those are going to be new
versions of all characters so they can
keep things the same without the actors
aging our roles and they can just keep
pumping the franchise for another 15
years I'm Star-Lord
now the final few scenes also tell us
what the other Guardians are going off
to do I've already talked about mantis
but Drax and nebula remain on nowhere
and together they start a new community
with some of the creatures and children
that they save from the high
evolutionary Drax gets to go back to
being a father which is pretty much the
thing he was fighting for this entire
time the guardian's done a knee there
and instead we see a new team being
formed that's led by Rocket Raccoon you
see groups turn into a gigantic version
of himself which I've seen referred to
as either Alpha Groot or King Groot kind
of picky poison with that as both these
versions are from the comics and though
I'll lean more towards this being the
king one I'm not mad if you referred to
him as Alpha you also have the good dog
Cosmo the space dog who has popped up a
lot in the movie so far she's been a big
part of the comics too and she's of
course based on the dogs that Russia
sent out to test space travel we even
get a little cccp badge on her chest
showing that she is connected the Soviet
Union now the group will sit around
waiting for some alien animals to arrive
so that they can protect their Village
and they talk about their favorite songs
ends with rocket playing come and get
your love by the band Redbone which I'm
sure you recognizes being from that
first movie now I discussed on the last
video what way they could take this and
currently we have lots of people out in
space that they could end up hooking up
with in the comics pip Patrol was one of
warlock's closest allies and because of
this I could see them bumping into Eros
and even the eternals we also have the
news that Galactus will be coming to the
MCU too and with the Marvels also taking
a further focus on Space we have these
Cosmic characters all out there doing
their own thing I'd love to see them
team up at some point and we could get a
Guardians of the Galaxy T made up of
space characters which mirrors The
Avengers on Earth just something I
thought about when watching it but I
think these characters will likely
return in secret Wars if they come back
Kang is gonna be the next major threat
so makes sense to have them all coming
together for that
[Applause]
I feel
my thoughts on the film I think that
this rounds out James Gunn's movies as
being some of the strongest in the MCU I
still probably prefer the Captain
America trilogy but it's difficult to
think of a better way that gun could
have closed at his run at Marvel there's
a lot of Bittersweet goodbyes and though
not everyone gets the ending that people
might have wanted it all still makes
sense rather than a feeling like the
studio said well these characters have
to end up together I feel like the movie
used the characters to drive their
decisions so I really appreciate stuff
like that instead of just feeling like
it's paint by numbers and it makes sense
to draw the line where they do and for
this to also be their final outing
everyone gets a timely shine here too
and every part of the team brings their
best performance I think that's the case
with gun 2 and you can tell he's
mastered his style and sensibilities and
is more than capable of directing big
Blockbusters like this honestly I know
everyone's saying that this kind of
saved the MCU but knowing that he's
going off to DC makes his departures
Bittersweet as Gamora is this definitely
helps steer the company back in the
right direction but he's now on his way
over to the competition so it could
potentially backfire on them either way
though in the moment I think this is a
great return to form and the perfect way
to close things out now I do have my
criticisms as well and though everyone's
saying that this is the best MCU movie
since endgame I still think that
Accolade belongs to no way home that
just impacted me a bit more as I think
its ending is one of the best we've ever
had in a comic book film and the deaths
and consequences that happen in it also
hit home a lot harder just getting
actors returning that I never thought
would smack me on a different level
which made that a stronger film in my
opinion I think that this movie could
have been done with cutting some things
down as well and there are moments I
feel a bit repetitive due to Gunn's
style at some point I feel like he just
has an action scene and puts a song Over
the Top to make it feel like we're on a
cool Journey with the characters which
once in a while can work really well but
at points I just thought this movie
became a bit too reliant on doing that
to the point it almost made certain
actions feel like they're just music
videos now when you're making a film
that has a composed score you also have
the music that's being created slowly to
work as part of the scene it's played in
when you grab a song from somewhere else
though that's it and sometimes the music
doesn't quite line up with the moments
in the same way a stylized soundtrack
would at points I feel like the guy's
just grabbed Now That's What I Call
movie soundtracks 55 and stuck it over
the top of some scenes but I suppose it
does give it its own personality I'm
just nitpicking as it does work 95 of
the time but I'm trying to make a
balanced review that has both positives
and negatives now do you think that the
high evolutionary did turn things up to
11 and some of the scenes I was like the
guy's literally just standing there
screaming can be good in its moments but
sometimes it can be over the top as well
and we see a lot of the characters just
shouting things at points I'm looking at
you nebula and mantis you know what I
mean I also think that's some of the
jokes follow James Gunn's signature
style of humor which is basically a
character saying something stupid
another character going you're more
[__] and then the character they're
calling are [__] doubling down and
saying something even more Dumber that's
kind of what a lot of the jokes fit into
but you know what I I have quite a
juvenile sense of humor you might have
guessed um so most of them hit for me
but there were just a couple here and
there that didn't fully hit the mark
still though we're batting at quite a
high average here and yeah I did find a
lot of moments fun especially that
F-bomb best part of the movie first
death Bob in the Marvel Universe and I
really enjoyed it also I've seen a lot
of people talking about how much gum
brings his friends and family into stuff
which they say can be quite distracting
now there are points where I can see the
valid points in that argument um and the
counter argument to that is always
something like well Martin Scorsese
works with Leonardo DiCaprio and Robert
De Niro all the time and I don't hear
you complaining about that you're
[__] [__] well I'm gonna play
devil's advocate here and I think the
difference is that De Niro's won
multiple Oscars us as DiCaprio and
before he was even cast in a Scorsese
movie he was in Titanic which was one of
the biggest films of all time they've
done stuff outside of their friends
director's films so the counter argument
kind of falls apart for me when when you
go into that I'm saying that you know
what to expect with a James good movie
and either this is gonna bother you that
his friends are in it or you're just not
gonna care I know that it's a criticism
a lot of people have but watching it in
this film I don't think that it's
anything to really ding this movie for
because his characters are just pop up
and they go as quickly as they come in
everything else around it's really well
written and his brother Sean's a
testament to how much having his family
involved can work so yeah whether that
harms the movie for you or not it is
going to be something that you have to
decide yourself now in the end this very
much feels like an ensemble piece in
which guns bringing together everything
he's learned and done since that first
Guardians film at this point the guy is
a master at his craft he's built this
relationship with the actors and though
I don't think some moments fully hit
their Target in the end it feels like he
stuck the landing on his Trilogy which
he should be uploaded for personally I
still prefer the first Guardians movie
but this is a very close second and
therefore I'm giving it an 8 out of 10.
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know are you excited to see what
gun does at DC do you think that
Marvel's gonna lose out losing him or do
you think they've finally learned what
they need to do lots of things to talk
about you know that there's things going
on behind the scenes with this movie as
well and I think there's lots of
interesting conversations that we could
have just please keep it respectful
maybe it's a comment section you're not
fighting a war here just calm down and
we'll have a good time now as to thank
you for doing that you'll be entered
into a competition where we're giving
away the quantumania steel Buck to three
subscribers on the 15th of May all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film you pick the comments at random
on the 15th and the winners are on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on Twitter heavy spoilers you
want me else to watch then make sure you
check our upright and have just the post
credit scenes in which we give our
theories about the characters in it and
where they could go with them huge thank
you for sticking through the video I've
been Paul and I hope you enjoy the rest
of your weekend really appreciate you
sitting to this point and I'll see you
next time take care peace